throughout this lesson in the last we've
discussed many ways to help you find and
connect with your audience because the
most challenging time for a new company
is when you start growing your user base
there are many tips out there to gain
your first thousand users and beyond
your first real users are critical these
are people who aren't just your friends
and family that are testing our app you
want to pay attention to what the real
people are saying about your app and how
their rating it now think about it from
your users point of view for a second
not many people are going to want to
download an app with only 10 downloads
so you'll need to show new users that
your app actually means something to the
people who are actually using it and who
are enjoying it now let's go back to our
entrepreneurs to learn a few more tips
about growing your user base and hearing
about the real world experience creating
companies that started just like yours
is today